oh my goodness 6 22 on your Thursday
wish you we had smell-o-vision you know
for the last two weeks we've been doing
the eight news now cook Insurance Burger
bracket yeah that's right oh sorry go
Heather well I was just gonna say we
started with 64 and now we're down to
the top four and one of those four is
right here fuku Burger yeah
Burger of course come welcome in this
morning thanks for filling our mornings
with Burgers enjoyment thanks for
honored to be here so uh first of all
let's talk about the business itself
long time folks notebook Burger of
course really really well what makes
that so good well it's all American
Burger so the Japanese twists uh
marinate to me in our own secret spices
um mainly I can show you base a secret
spice so it gives it a definite uh
Japanese flavor to it you can tell um
just by the first bite oh for sure I
can't argue obviously people love you I
mean you're in the top four but for
folks who have not been there where are
you located and when can they get one of
these Burgers themselves so the business
started as a food truck uh we have a
couple locations uh around town one on
Buffalo and um Warm Springs in the South
Side one uh on in Chinatown at um Jones
and Spring Mountain okay and then our uh
our big one is at the Elysian Stadium on
the section 128.
what's the biggest seller what's the
best one so probably one number two and
a number three this is actually number
three it's a Buddha apple smoked bacon
cheeseburger okay uh it's with um by the
way our buns are locally sourced through
grape buns like oh shout out like local
as possible our purveyors Nicholas who's
uh the owners actually are live in Vegas
uh you see uh American cheese
um like I said Apple it's about making
cheeseburger it's a support beer reduced
barbecue sauce uh Wasabi mail and the
the ginger on top is the kizami sugar
it's uh it's a little ginger slices to
give it a very distinct flavor
too right yeah yeah and carrots here uh
this is the ginger that's the ginger
yeah and then you guys put some more
squirrel sauce on here too that was the
uh the uh um support rare reduced
barbecue sauce and then Wasabi meal so
we've been highlighting all of these uh
for the uh for the burger bracket here
what's the burger industry culture like
in town not just fuku Burger but there's
so many places in town uh what what is
the Burger scene in Las Vegas well I'll
tell you what I always promote the local
the locally owned ones
um barcode my buddy Cody owns that one
right down the street on Flamingo uh
Nevada Brew Works I mean you don't have
to go through these National chains to
get a really great burger in Vegas
this is some good looking beef here man
yeah sorry all Local 80 20. we uh fluff
it up that's probably the secret to it
it's like air is uh real dense Burger
you want nicely uh
yeah get in there get in there guys
don't forget you have until Sunday to
vote for the best burger in town and
this is the Burger of bracken you see
the final four right on your screen
right there go online vote if you can
and uh thanks again for calling for
coming in today I really appreciate it
this morning we are so hungry right now
we're improvising with all this it's not
usually my husband's gonna be so jealous
we live down the street it's like his
favorite spot um
next time yeah what's up with that okay